and produces amazon and binds gold mining
mister state of the land and with mining
company the toxic by rampant product
child by places when it disappears
efe goldberg sports league the defender
children now you dress
considerations
[Music]
fifteen present the product of the blow
export only girl one point billion
dollars saw Iberian passing not
makes stop stop illegal export solid gold
price is kate's peace power the bill
of sensibility mind and ranging
destruction dollars
the rainforest
of 6 jones jardel and stable
surprise snow of own bosses brand and
fake katy
myers where they probably declare
older and in such a way version
yesterday in your port maldonado capital the
produces mother of god provence at goal
william gallas big and the destination x
files and sex traffic children formats
Of cancer
luis alberto sánchez
traffic
and harvest bread so that what happens and the
Pampa is an area where
large-scale illegal mining that brings
of like related crimes
the trafficking of people sicariato rape
extortion the operatives that
we develop what we develop on the day
because at night enter it to
do not leave luis alberto office jesús
setting so request victims of film
and trafficking of corridor mouse
sexual exploited minor takes out any
Puerto Maldonado is still the phenomenon
of generalized trafficking also problem
of protection of minors within the
city ​​also develops but it is a
most hidden issue is a more closed topic
very many
darling wuilleret puerto maldonado red
light district two figures the show
chase or philibert was in fact 5
plus
there you have me flying
a file does not get through the operative you
you carry
i
[Music]
your name is not
but a lot of girls around here are
much younger than a certain
Really
in the pampas
Hello
[Music]
one day
because your death more
she does not return
[Music]
that is, the other would be something
ladies
Y
how nice
mining and the pampa the internal
leiter the night is alberto drugs to
kilometer hours
out transactions was between point to
the pampa the waters style away from the
remote martín camps kilometer white and
civilly catherine the knights of
those also in and out cordillera
and we finished
and if Alberto is the father of the Wi-Fi
profile form the graphic question of the
humor about word transversal
[Music]
the profile of the micro
more or less information
when the time of the former mill whose
company luís alberto allaire whiskey
johnnie to handle down south trafiques
living of the pampa save mining camps
johnny more than one footballer
in the mother traffic of god until the
process of expulsion of camps order of
operation
followed by the albertos face texas right
life in the apples psychosis plan
You must jones in order to avoid leaks
not even the most novel police right
policemen in projects word plane clouds
to try to make the two and a half way in
into the mining camps have detected
order to police records murders a report
indies loles was an angel and daily faces
of zinebi almost apocalyptic gil mother
of god provins the fake fifty
rainforest rabbin injectors 'destroyed'
tot the witches bite them heart and
fictional inject is illegal mining
[Music]
the faith of ambition and mein tweets
kampf side non as the rock the show with
Festivals of Luis Alberto warned
soccer of uol esporte
[Applause]
and the traffic
by one of the score
Miss cities no longer has another
in andré
love
they are accounts as has arrived
[Music]
and as he says nothing
please how is your profit with 20
soles, how much do you earn for that?
There are some ladies who see us
get there they have run away from the miss is
minor but they found themselves in a
adjacent to the traffickers when
they see fiscal police presence
disappear again but there are many
ways to know who is the driver of
these neighborhoods found the counter of
uncle hooks
in order to restrict there is nothing
January cut
[Music]
here it looks very even
yes
and put it to work
[Music]
au ments later of huesca
they collect clouds and women on the host
snics current web in chickens hard with
fire insights massive media shelters in
corbis damos
[Music]
I left Welsh Wayne Rainey Trees Rubbish
of angel cappa in law
[Music]
but what is hidden in one of the
environments but how is a big if the
population could not be verified one by
one in the owner of the lodging
[Music]
[Applause]
but she
when
[Music]
it was a mark on luis alberto and that's
to be able to swim place the ones to be
investigate your truck
here apparently there are also other
other females and they are still
[Music]
all goals
let's do
[Music]
we're going to take all that team of
low computation because there is information
data from the list
a few days ago he presented a
complaint against you
and right now we are finding here
in this bar
[Music]
deposit situation is serious is
delicate right now
we left we three people red state park
for girls times 15
improve your feed when indicated where we
came in the new taxi driver
wanted to be seen alpine ofertix
[Music]
back in puerto maldonado willis and you'll
salter a flavor of rsc and wells likely
to spend the next end
one
salute hello how are you this is the room
host where we provide the
protection in victims who
remain until the prosecutor sees what
is convenient for them many of
they are families
intrafamily
and apart also with problems of
sexual intercourse even within the
family
good are two minors who are here
and the other here and good for the moment
it is has the girls who are now
same here
the development minister wrap it in place
jones and the president of the
congressional commission for women rights
the visit in puerto maldonado to address
from your trafficking regime to the press
conference representative to the original
seriously express 3 with 6
[Music]
ten thousand soles to do all the
jobs
someone is urgently required to
construction of the center of attention
Residential specialized in victims of
entries has a series forward
of tasks we would like to join us in
the tasks so that we can all created
feel that on this road we see
alone
bismarck the king place in port
maldonado commemorates from national day
and him and trafficking includes
publishes wellness and we sing the place
of worth found el carmen a beijing 2
working to start graphic
madrid- verbal limited fans available to
fight and illegal golf industry awards
hundred milion swallowed an email in
airplane
[Music]